[Musique]
le rendez-vous que nous proposons c'est
une manifestation festive mais surtout
informative sur le dépistage et la lutte
contre le cancer du sein
l'organisation a été faite par
l'ensemble du conseil municipal de la
mairie de Cernay-la-Ville et c'est
associé au Cabaret du bout des prés donc
tout son équipe administrative et son
équipe artistique
[Musique]
cette manifestation s'adresse à tout le
monde nous avons fait en sorte de
pouvoir mélanger l'information avec le
divertissement pour vous donner une idée
cette opération commencera à 18h30 avec
une marche de la mairie de
Cernay-la-Ville jusqu'au cabaret du bout
des prés une marche des femmes et cette
marche sera accompagnée des hommes et
des enfants avec des lampions rose qui
les accompagneront qui représenteront le
cœur des femmes voilà donc ça ça
concerne bien évidemment tout le monde
toute la population on a besoin de tous
simplement parce que l'équipe est en
majorité des femmes alors même si le
cancer du sein concerne les hommes et
les femmes c'est souvent plus souvent
les femmes qui sont concernées par cette
maladie et ça nous touche bien
évidemment encore plus puisque
le corps des des femmes et des danseuses
et leur outil de travail
et donc le cancer du sein est quelque
chose qui pourrait les concerner et que
nous avons envie de combattre
[Musique]